All right. So what do we do at the end? We have,
here's what we do at the end of the thing is we do something called unhelpful
advice. Okay. And they ask a question and then we have to answer it. All right.
Can you do it? Thank you. Okay. He has to do a thing though.
And what's going on there?
Oh, helpful advice with Bobby Khalilah at, uh,
you know, y'all.
That was a remix. Most people like it.
St. Queen and Prince and court jester. A few years ago,
I was lost and doing nothing with my life. However,
my girlfriend helped set me on the right path.
And now I have a rewarding career in software development. Most, if not all,
all of my sets, I owe my hard work and perseverance to her.
My question is how can I help her set her on the right path?
She's unhappy with her current job. And it seems like she's got one or two good,
but risky options to get out,
but has yet to really make a move on them and is unsure.
I'm feeling terrible that I can't help her out. What do I do Carlo from Canada?
Uh, that was what?
How does.
He, okay. The question is the girlfriend set him up on a good path.
She was there for him. So how does he return? How does he leave her? Um,
he wants to return the favor or Levi's setting her up.
No, he wants to, uh, he wants to do the same thing for.
Her too. He wants to get her a good.
Job or on the right path. Yeah. Follow her dreams.
Essentially. Yeah. That's like the hardest thing you could ever buy for someone.
Yeah. Well, first of all, we don't even know what her dreams are.
You can put a blindfold on and then just make sure that she's walking the right
way.
Say it's risky. So it's probably like, not a normal nine to five.
So if she isn't there.
You mean a risky, like a coal miner kind of situation.
I want to say something right now. Could I stand, stand, stand up,
whatever she wants to do. You should always support that. Right.
So I don't know what her dream is, but yeah. I don't know specifics,
but you should try to help her make it. Yeah.
I think all women need is just to be told that you can it's okay.
We support you. Yeah. That's all only need for men.
There's a second question here. This one's a good one.
Can I just say something real quick though?
I've been really getting into X-Factor and I've been really getting into this
lady by the name of Sam Bailey. She won the whole thing 2013.
And when she auditioned, right,
she was like this like frumpy white lady who just had kids and a wife.
She likes soccer and she's like, I think I'm too old. But um, you know,
I have to try she's British and she won the whole thing. She's so gifted.
There you go. Wait.
Is that one, the one that you make you eat bugs and stuff? No.
[Inaudible].
She does a singing competition and she won the whole thing. But when,
whenever I look at that clip in the beginning,
[inaudible].
Ugly. Susan Boyle road rode through and everyone thought she was, you know,
Susan was not even that lit. What do you mean? She's not,
I don't think she's like that. And she didn't blow me away, but you know, why?
Why? Because she looked like.
No, because, well, let me say.
This right now. If she didn't look like that and.
She looked like, she looked like just a regular 20 or two year old girl,
hip girl, she would have been, she wouldn't have made it.
Yeah. She went [inaudible].
When she came out of that stage, people laughed in the audience and they, they,
you know, and then she came out and did that.
I think that had a lot to do with their, her look. But this girl, Sam Bailey,
I'm talking about, isn't like that she's legitimately talented.
But when she said I have to try,
it makes me cry because in life you always have to try.
Yeah. And that's tonight's message.
Give second question. Second question. Go ahead.
Me and my.